we begin in Moldova where Ukrainian
President Vladimir zielinski has joined
the leaders of 47 countries for the
European political Community Summit it's
the second time the Gathering has been
held it aims to bolster unity in the
face of Russia's invasion of Ukraine
I think what is very important our
future in EU and
and Ukraine is ready to be in NATO we
are waiting when NATO will be ready to
host and to see and to have Ukraine and
I think security guarantees are very
important not only for Ukraine for our
neighbor's home although because of of
the Russia and of their aggression in
Ukraine and potential aggression for
other parts of Europe
well Stephanie Decker is live for us at
the meeting now and we've seen European
leaders slowly arrive throughout the
morning there Ukraine obviously will be
on the G on the agenda what else are
they going to be discussing there today
yes well that opening ceremony you
probably have life pictures of that
taking place behind that glass wall
behind us the leaders then we'll be
coming out for what's called a family
photo photo opportunity before they then
go away for their discussions also
bilateral talks and a working lunch of
course you mentioned there Ukraine very
high on the agenda here we heard
um from the Ukrainian leader of Vladimir
zielinski being the first to arrive I
don't think that was by chance
um saying that he called for a support
European support NATO on the ground in
the air against what he called Russian
aggression you heard him there also
called for the same to be applied to
Moldova other things they're going to be
discussing here things like security
cyber security we also heard from the
host
moldova's president Maya Sandu as she
opened the conferencing that also things
like climate change and energy these
kinds of topics of discussion so it's a
very broad table of topics if you will
of course Ukraine right up there but you
do have a vast array of European power
here for the next couple of hours in
this Castle in this Vineyard which
actually was interesting the moldovan
president uh
contrasting the peacefulness of where we
are to Ukrainian border just around 20
kilometers away so the interesting thing
about this conference is that even
though there's so many things that can
be discussed there is no pressure there
is no agenda nothing will be signed in
the end of this day and just how
difficult has it been to I guess arrange
this meeting especially given that it is
so close to Ukraine
foreign
yes I mean security Wise It's been a
mammoth uh task if you will we
interviewed one of Moldova was actually
the deputy speaker of parliament
yesterday and he said you know we
politicians like to call these events
historic he said from Moldova this is
historic they've never hosted uh such an
array of power if you will everyone
we've seen here you have you know the
French President you have Georgia
Maloney of Italy you you have all the
European leaders really
um and that comes with security
Logistics that comes the Aerospace has
been closed since midnight uh today we
had to take a train around six o'clock
this morning two trains organized for
journalists and sort of the the lower
ends of the delegation if you will to
make it to here because everything
surrounding this area the roads have
been blocked off men with heavy machine
guns guarding the area NATO also
involved in surveillance of the Skies
here so that gives you a sense of just
how difficult and how massive the
operation is to host this it's only
going to last a couple of hours but
certainly for Moldova we're which has
the unfortunate title of being one of
Europe's poorest countries it is quite a
feat to have pulled this off and they're
also a very ambitious if you will to try
and show the leaders here that they have
made the reforms necessary to join the
EU which of course is also a demand of
Ukraine so all these issues up for
discussion but certainly the message
from the government here is that they
can host all of these safely and that it
should be a positive step towards
gaining that EU membership okay thank
you very much that is Stephanie Decker
for us in Moldova